for the first time since 2015 Facebook
founder Mark Zuckerberg isn't one of the
10 richest people in America since
September 2021 Zuckerberg lost more than
half of his fortune a staggering 76.8
billion dollars dropping him from the
number three spot on the Forbes 400 list
of the US's wealthiest people to number
11. no one in America has lost as much
money over the past year as Zuckerberg
he has the cratering stock price of meta
to thank for his exit from the top 10.
shares have plunged 57 percent since
last year's Forbes 400 which used stock
prices from September 3rd 2021. tech
stocks are generally in a slump with the
market downturn but meta's fall outpaces
both the NASDAQ and the S P 500 as well
as Microsoft's 14 decline Google parent
alphabet's 25 percent drop and Amazon's
27 dive investors are spooked by a
privacy policy update from Apple last
year that made it harder for tech
companies to track users across apps
impacting meta's ad sales meta reported
its first ever quarterly Revenue decline
in July a one percent drop to 28.8
billion dollars
compounding the problem for meta Tick
Tock is luring away advertisers along
with lucrative gen Z and Millennial
users in February meta announced its
first ever quarterly loss of daily
active users worth 57.7 billion dollars
on this year's list which used stock
prices from September 2nd Zuck Trails
Walmart air Jim Walton former New York
City Mayor Michael Bloomberg and even
Tech Moguls like Steve Ballmer and
Sergey Brin this year isn't the first
time Zuckerberg's net worth has taken a
dive after Facebook's disappointing IPO
in 2012 Zuckerberg fell from number 14
to number 36 on the Forbes 400 but it
didn't last long the following year
Zuckerberg bounced back and up until now
his fortune has continued to climb
despite the Litany of controversies and
Scandals plugging the company Facebook's
ad machine had reliably churned out
enough money to impress investors
sending Zuckerberg's net worth soaring
to 134.5 billion dollars last year his
highest net worth ever
foreign